satirizing quadratic expressions you are
going to spit for your wife driving
quadratic expression so we want to get
really good at what you go to something
a lot more enjoyable a quadratic
expression is the very first thing that
you wrote down when you finish the
question one today well not the first
thing the last thing this six year
that's a quadratic expression can anyone
tell me what is it that makes that why
milk the answer what is it that makes
that a quadratic anyone know what's the
key piece of information
hmm now quadratically were funny woman
or dreaded because it suggests for right
for like we would think binomials - okay
except actually it's really to do with
the fact that see this x-squared term
right a square has how many signs the
quadratic means that you've got
something squared followed by a few
other things that are related okay I
could give you probably a more technical
definition that's a little more precise
but for our purposes that's all that
will mean if you can see it as something
squared x squared a squared T squared
anything like that that's a quadratic
expression okay now the first question I
gave you is expand so they're going down
this way we've expanded so what would it
mean to faster eyes if you just just go
in reverse
okay so faster izing means turning x
squared plus 5x plus 6 plus u into X
plus 2 X plus okay so what I want you to
see is the expanded form is a son you're
adding a whole bunch of things together
and that's what the expression is but
we're trying to turn it into what's it
called will you find yourself repeating
what return sum into a fact
this is part of my this topic is called
products and factors so this is the job
we're trying to do we know how to go on
one direction quite easily how can we go
in reverse hold on to your hats I'm
going to teach you the up steps for the
recipe okay I'm going to show you how
you can it is quite quickly but what I'm
not going to show you immediately is why
it works I'm just going to point out
that it does have a look at these
numbers here this is what you might be
given as a question and then here are
the numbers that you have to come up
with as the answer I wonder if you can
see a connection between the numbers
here and the numbers here don't yell out
just yet think about it see you there
and you think about that I'm going to
give you another example just underneath
and maybe it will make the pattern a
little theorem if instead I asked you to
factorize sorry which is that color so
as you can see if instead I asked you to
factorize this what you end up with is
this
can anyone see and articulate what's the
pattern going on how do I come up with
those two numbers Jade Matthew Hale
universe two and three in the sacrum yes
that of the five
yes and they also multiply together to
make Nick can we say that again because
that was perfect for these two numbers
here the ones you've ended up with after
you factorize they add up to this number
attached to the X the coefficient of x
and they multiply to this guy
the constant okay so let's try and
summarize them because you can see it's
the same time yeah I think underneath
what you've written is available to
factorize
[Music]
x squared plus BX plus C I'm going to
explain next lesson why I chose these
particular letter B and see where they
come from
if you get a quadratic expression that
looks like this there's number B an
undersea like say five and six or seven
and twelve right what do I do is search
for books sorry for the color search for
a pair of numbers that you can watch a
defense you said they add up to this
middle one in this case of five in this
case it was seven so we wanted to add up
to that guy beer add artists to be be is
called the coefficient of x because it's
attached to the X but I just want any
numbers that add up to be right we want
exactly a particular pair not just a 0
and 5 or 1 4 we want 2 & 3 specifically
because they also how do we say they
multiply to give see that last ones on
the end okay this is their constant or
the number why they called the constant
by the way have a look at these guys why
are you guys not called the clustered
you know they can change their very
important we call not just pretty more
about variables because we can let them
have different values right so just
searching for a pair numbers and that's
how I read this okay so wonder if you
can help me work out as another example
1d Serpine I gave you this
think what do you see honey you can see
how it's really important when we spent
back in your set in time learning how to
factorize just numbers right part of
what we were leading to is so you can
look at that and lickety-split you can
say 2 times 14 7 times 4 28 times 1
those are all your options and you can
fire through them and think oh ok which
one is going to add up to 11 so I just
show you 3 fairly straightforward
examples where the numbers are small and
they're quite easy to identify okay but
they're not always so straightforward
example x squared / 6 okay I bet you're
now on the board you haven't seen any
motorcycles okay
what's going to go on here it's the same
idea I'm still searching for a pair of
numbers I still want to add them to add
up to or on very minor the ends up just
waiting to all get there I want them to
add up to what what's the what's the
color vision of X if the Navy wants for
high genic I'm even going to write
negative 1 because the number is there
it's just implied I want me to add up to
negative 1 I want them to multiply to
give negative 6
well clearly at least one of these
numbers well in fact only one of these
numbers has to be negative right by the
way why can't they be negative because
then you wouldn't get a negative 6 would
you okay so what are we a plus want to
be a - okay I'll make you see the
numbers
now one of the lovely things about this
is if you're ever in doubt they're like
first I don't know
later on we'll get quite confusing
because you learn to do so many you
liked it I confirm did I get the minuses
around the right way are you sure it's
not X minus 2 X plus 3 you can just
check because we're really good at
expanding right so just off on the side
if you're ever in doubt you just scroll
you know in a messy way okay let's do
the expansion this and then this help me
out first one you don't need to do any
more you need to get to the end because
you are told I've all the pieces that I
wanted I bought the X square I got the
minus six and then you can see what's
going to happen to these by so that's
enough of a mental check
does that make sense so you can confirm
for yourself that it works